you ready
your weapon
will kill the ultimate forged and fired
matchup you are the forest and fire
Champion two Champion plays in a deadly
weapon Showdown it will kill 20 blades
20 Champions you decide the winner
forged in fire Madness
[Music]
a pair of bog not named Chad Hatfield
and I'm a full-time iron worker being an
iron worker really helps me in the Forge
because we know a bunch of types to
steal we work with torches we work with
hand tools all the time so I am going to
win
meeting Tigers Club bug knock was
ruthless weapon originating from India
while concealed in the hand it could
serve up surprise attacks resulting in
deep gashes that pierce through both
skin and muscle this variation was
called the B Schwab bad knock and
included a lethal blade that was made to
resemble the sting of a scorpion this
design made it a triple threat where it
could either thrust slash or claw its
way into an opponent one of the most
well-known uses of the weapon is
recounted in the history of the Morata
Empire when Emperor shivaji secretly
wore a bognac and fatally disemboweled
his enemy
here or knives my name is Nick I'm the
owner and soul Smith of the red troll
Forge I do demonstrations on
blacksmithing and try to keep people
entertained most people know me as
Grendel the big red troll I'm having a
good time
deer horn knives are distinctive
double-bladed weapons used as an
extension of the body to counter and
disarm opponents the knives are unique
to the 19th century martial art form
hogwash young students of this
discipline train with the weapon in both
hands to master techniques in slashing
and seizing easily concealed in
traditional Chinese Garb these Mighty
knives can be swiftly brandished to
catch an opponent off guard and deliver
deadly Cuts with four horn Shake points
the weapons are notably employed in the
film Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
I'm at my home Forge I'm excited let's
get this started
I'm using Damascus because if it comes
down to Aesthetics that might give me an
edge to my competitor I want a nice bold
pattern and hopefully at the end of the
day I have the bill it's done I turned
off beautiful
I'm liking it claws are even it's time
to get ready for heat treat there's five
blades that I have to heat treat on one
blade so it's very difficult
that is a very straight blade time for
the second one
I'm liking it it looks really nice I'm
gonna put on the leather wrap for the
handles to give it a little extra grip
and to conceal the welds that I put on
there
I'll test it and see if I like it
I think it'll be sufficient for stabbing
it can take a lot of abuse and also has
a sharp edge
it's Sharp
I feel really confident about these
blades I can't wait to see them being
tested
I'm back on my home Forge ready to make
a really strange Chinese weapon my big
wow factor for this one is actually
doing it out of Damascus a few layers of
Steel stacked together forged welded
together to make them one piece and we
go
Steels don't quite mix so you get this
nice pattern going through it
there's two basic ways you can make this
weapon one is to take one large piece of
Steel to make Cuts in it and then bend
it all out into shape what I'm going to
try to do is make it into two separate
Crescent shapes and Forge well where
they overlap
so I decided to do a butt weld I'm going
to be cutting the crescents apart and
Welding it flat on so now the edges will
line up looks very nice ready to do the
heat treat no no no I don't want to go
in the fire again yeah
my only concern right now is if this
weird shape decides to warp it all
it could be a problem into the quench
there we go
that is as hard as the file they didn't
warp into a pretzel so hey I'm great
all I have left to do is put the handles
on and sharpen the blades putting the
handles on is shaping the material a
little bit gluing them on drilling the
holes and putting the pins in place to
hold everything together and it's all
ready to go
there's seven different edges on this
thing just freaking dangerous it's all
nice and sharp now let's see what we can
do with this
okay
I don't want to get hit by it
Lee Smith to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do won't take
your bag knock and deliver multiple
slashes and thrust and Claw at this big
carcass all right Chad your turn you
ready yes sir
[Music]
all right Chad first up the handle it's
on the thinner side there's a little bit
of movement there but the positions
where you have the claw is secure it's
safe they're razor sharp on the
lacerations there the slicing it cuts
deeply overall your weapon will kill
thank you well RJ and I can see your
fighting skills have not changed since
we were kids you still scratch like a
girl cat class
to see how lethal your weapon is I will
deliver multiple slashes and thrusts on
this pig carcass Nick you're next you
ready oh yeah
foreign
is very sharp grabbing your handle it
feels smooth with both scales in there
the angles you have really lacerate
deeply and overall your weapon will kill
you good job thank you
let's Miss to test the strength and
durability of your bognark I'm going to
be clawing and stabbing away at these
logs remember this test is all about
what happens to your blades not what
happens to the log Chad you're up next
you ready yes sir
Well Chad
you lost one of your tips the other one
was scaring me but it's in one piece it
held up well I like that you did
Damascus I like the pattern of it it's
really pretty
overall well done thank you
to test the strength of your weapons
we're going to clamp them into our
Contraption back here once triggered a
staff will strike the center section of
each of the blades one time with the
force of two thousand pounds simulating
the kind of attacks these weapons could
historically encounter in combat Nick
just waiting for it waiting for it in
one two three
and it broke the stick
three two one
[Music]
and it broke the stick again all right
well first off let's remember that the
test wasn't about breaking sticks it was
more about how your blade reacts to
being hit by that stick
well there is
no damage whatsoever this is still a
razor blade
oh nicely done it thank you
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blades I'll be clawing
and slashing at our Sandman here unlike
the strength test this is all about what
your weapons do to this target all right
Chad you're up you ready yes sir
foreign
these are amazingly sharp each one of
those cuts is beautiful and clean
they're very light very fast I think you
did a beautiful job these are very nice
weapons thank you
to see how sharp your weapons are I will
take your weapons and deliver multiple
slashes and stabs on this ballistic bag
the bag is outfitted with two posts
which simulates blocks or blows from
pole weapons these knives will encounter
in battle Nick you're up next you ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
well you can see that it penetrates deep
the angles you have them in and last
rates out they're comfortable in the
hand and your blades will cut
thank you now it's your turn which
weapon will you choose forged in fire
Madness